I wanna get that baby coach found my
latest cheat name and centerpiece you
see Tom is getting old and needs extra
protection
well then apply anti-aging organic I
black made from the ashes of Jimmy
Garoppolo contract extension Giselle was
wrong one day I will throw and catch the
game light reps for the normal players
meditation for Toms cold ok thanks
here's my special mind power Tom the
Patriots doing a rebuild we reload um
coach are we cool now
oh hi coach have you met our terrible
back up yet hello I'm Thomas whoops
hahaha thank goodness for the Tuck rule
Thanos didn't go far enough I collected
all six coach we can finally retire
coach I'll do it I'll move I don't think
about you as much as you think I do
boy the Jets were tough I don't know how
we did it but yo if you got to someone
selfie doesn't become an elite video
I'm footballs Tom Brady please buy my
special pliability Roombas why would I
do that
can't you get hi I'm Joan Edelman and I
know Tom Brady please subscribe to this
channel